all right let's do this one last time
you're a bit late can't all be
everywhere at once little text might
have been nice I was gone for less than
two hours what happened okay okay I know
what it looks like but here's the good
news
oh here we go the multiverse didn't pull
out oh cool it'll work yeah great story
hey did you finish the goober it's not a
goober it's a gizmo you always have to
call me out this is really frustrating
don't get too excited Miguel it's just a
prototype not excited but you could be
the first person to make an autonomous
multiverse jump or the last okay so
we're just going to roll the dice on this
what do you say pal where you want to go
first let's start at the beginning one
last time earth 67. Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Sony just dropped the
spider-man into the spider verse two
teaser and we already know a whole bunch
about the movie so we'll break it down
I do Easter Egg videos every week if
you're brand new to my channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything I will
think of some fun spider-verse giveaway
to do and all my spider-man videos
because there is a lot of spider-man
related movie stuff happening in the
next two years but right after the first
movie came out and was a huge critical
and financial success we all knew that
they were working on a sequel even the
producers were talking about it the
reason why they're only just releasing
this now is because after the first one
came out all the people that worked on
the first one which is amazing needed a
short break and they needed to figure
out what the story of the sequel would
be and figure out how long it would take
to make it so they could pick a release
date which wound up being April 8th 2022
the first one came out December 2018 so
if you're wondering why it's taking them
almost four years to make the sequel
it's because that's about how long it
took them to make the first film it took
a long time
also some Easter eggs from that teaser
when they're glitching between the
different spider-man versions and the
different logos they flashed the logo
from the 1978 Japanese spider-man TV
series implying he'll plays some role or
cameo during the movie at some point and
they flash the logo from the 1990s
animated spider-man TV show implying
that they'll incorporate some elements
from that too this could also be
representative of Jessica drew symbol
and this one could also be Ben Riley
there's also some theories that this one
represents mr. negative because he's
character they used in the spider-man
ps4 games longtime comic book spider-man
villain would make sense they would try
to include him in the spider-verse
movies at some point there are also a
lot of people that are wondering if this
might represent carnage or some sort of
twist on the Venom symbiote but I don't
think that they would do carnage before
they do venom we already know a little
bit about the basic plot and the
characters in the ending scene from the
first movie in that last spider-man 2099
post-credit scene are really big teasers
and Easter eggs for how the sequel will
work they kind of already told you how
they're going to accomplish that because
the whole premise of the first movie is
that kingpin uses the machine to crack
open the multiverse or the spider verse
as you call it in the spider-man comics
there's even webs connecting the
different dimensions in the background
where they're all falling through two
miles as Earth from the ultimate
spider-man comics so they really are
literally doing spider verse they
destroy that machine at the end of the
movie kingpin is in jail and most of the
sinister six and other major spider-man
villains have been neutralized or aren't
smart enough to reconstruct that
multiverse device so you ask how do they
bring back the characters from the first
movie for another team up on miles as
Earth and any new characters that they
want to add to the team so here's the
thing they already answered that
question with the ending scene where
after the events of the main movie
there's a short-time jump in spider-gwen
opens a portal above miles is said to
just chat him up from her universe and
if it wasn't clear that is supposed to
be happening in a relatively short
amount of time after they all go back to
their universes at the end of the movie
so she really is skyping him from her
universe then they explained how she did
that in the spider-man 2099 post-credits
scene
Miguel O'Hara spider-man 2099 played by
Oscar Isaac himself if he didn't
recognize his voice constructs a
futuristic goober based on the web where
risk devices from the spider-verse
comics that allows him to travel the
multiverse or the spider-verse at free
will and he can do it with precision he
can set exactly where in time in space
he wants to go he goes back in time to
the very first spider-man 1960s animated
TV show to recreate that pointing gif
whoa what I'm spider-man I need you to
come with me
I just told you that listen listen I'm
from the future how dare you point at me
you were pointing first rude to point
you're being very rude you're not even
as awesome as that was they were also
using that post-credit scene to sort of
set up the logic of how the seat wall
can work those devices are straight out
of the spider-verse comics and Jessica
drew Spider Woman uses them to assemble
a team of spider-man versions from
alternate universes to go on missions
across the spider-verse
so at some point after the events of the
main story of the movie they all go home
spider-gwen must have been given one of
those devices by spider-man 2099
implying that he would have a bigger
role in the sequel and there would be a
bigger time travel element in the story
they already used time travel in the
first movie if that wasn't clear so
spider-man noir played by Nicolas Cage
was hilarious but he actually comes from
depression 1930s era then penny Parker
with her Evangelion mech come from the
distant future even further in the
future from Miguel O'Hara's spider-man
2099 so they were already time-traveling
in that movie so it's no big deal to
have people from other points and time
and other universes show up in
present-day on miles as earth right now
for the sequel the only confirmed
characters we know are coming back are
Hailee Steinfeld spider-gwen because of
developing a spin-off movie for her and
then miles of course
maybe Jake Johnson's Peter B Parker just
because he was so amazing part of his
arc at the end of the film too was them
implying that he finally wanted children
and reconciled with his version of Mary
Jane on his earth and they would go on
to have a daughter
Mayday Parker from the spider-man comics
if you're not a big reader of the
spider-man comics there is a comic where
she grows up to succeed him as
spider-man taking the name spider girl
because time-travel is already a really
common thing in these movies they can
use time travel to explain how an older
or maybe a young version of Peter's
daughter can join the franchise but
here's the thing about the story in
escalation the whole concept of these
spider-verse movies is that they're
doing a version of the spider-verse
comics eventually once they introduced
the concept of the multiverse and the
web of life and destiny they reveal that
there's a bigger multiverse level
villain that's trying to destroy or
consume different spider people called
one that doesn't mean that more lund is
going to be the villain of the sequel
but part of the idea with these animated
movies is that you can do any story you
want budget isn't a factor in terms of
scope like it is for live-action movies
they can go as big as they want and what
is the natural escalation of the
spider-verse comics it's a story called
spider geddon which is just a even bigger
crossover that's sort of the spider
verse comics version of Avengers
infinity war in Avengers endgame and
because the first movie was such a big
hit for them they also confirmed that
they're developing all these spin-off
movies and additional sequels in a bunch
of live-action spider-verse TV shows
really cool inside baseball Easter Egg
from the first movie - originally they
talked about including live-action
elements as part of the many different
versions of Spider Man that appeared
during the movie Tom Holland also
revealed recently that they originally
plan to have him cameo as his MCU Spider Man in the movie and Lord and Miller the
producers also said they discussed about
bringing back Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield as their versions of spider-man
so there is no limit to the level of
craziness that they will eventually get
to and yes once Tom Holland Tobey and
Andrew Garfield cameo as their
spider-man versions that effectively
cannon eise's their movies to this
larger spider-verse that they're
creating with the animated movies that's
also kind of the idea of how you can
explain MCU spider-man hopping between the MCU movies and the venom movies or
that toby's spider-man exists in an
alternate universe even Peter B Parker
was created to be an amalgam of all the
previous versions of spider-man in the
movies like when he's telling his
backstory a lot of the scenes that they
show are scenes from Tobey Maguire's
spider-man movies the only totally new
concept that I believe that they'll
introduce in the sequel is the concept
of venom because we didn't really get
into any symbiotes or anything like that
during the first spider first movie but
if they talked about including Tom
Holland as his version of spider-man in
these movies then I think that they
would also try to get Tom Hardy to cameo
as his version of venom in the animated
spider-verse movies at some point
everyone post all your theories for
spider-verse
to in the comments and I will do more
spider-man and venom 2 videos soon but
everybody click here for my venom 2 teaser
video and click here for my
Doctor Strange 2 Ghost Rider video
thank you so much for watching everybody, stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight!